hi guys you can see me i'm back on the
road
having so much fun you can see me at the
brea improv
with josh potter opening for me on just
one night
uh the 27th of this very month and then
you can see me
again um august 27th and 29th
at the hartford funny bone on september
30th to october 2nd you can see me at
the
house of comedy in dallas
hi i'm esther i'm kalylah i'm annie
and we're in palm springs and i don't
know why
well well here's what happened esther
you said you were going on a family
vacation
wait a second you're not allowed to have
any fun without us
yeah are we not family [ __ ] i'm sorry i
guess we have to crash this and show her
how important we are to her
annie and i called each other we said
pack your little [ __ ] bags we're going
to crash this
love family love affair and i found my
[ __ ] outfit
her sailor taylor's outfit
so here we are we're in some some
version of a super eight
annie chose tacky the colors are bright
the nicest term i've ever been in i
don't know what you guys are talking
about so welcome to
our last minute palm springs episode
plus my parents
are here
so far it has been a hit or a bust
i think it's a i think it's a hit thus
far it's been about i've been here for
15 minutes nothing crazy has happened
george did forget the big bananas so
that is an issue
that will need to be worked out within
the next one do you not have any snacks
for us
um like i said it was hard work bringing
the baby for the first time
oh that's right i don't care about your
baby [ __ ] okay
your wife has to handle the baby you're
just the guy okay i actually handled the
baby for
an hour in my arms here oh his baby here
did you shake him a little you're so
cute i couldn't do anything but just
stare
oh i love little things oh
tommy my young man is here and he went
over to tj maxx to get me a swimsuit
got me two options your dog or your your
husband
my husband
are you trying to get a joint wedding i
was listening to you talk about todd on
a
previous episode and you're talking
about who's dying first
it's like well there's listen that's
marriage
babe is of death it is
well all my boyfriends i think that with
that one will die that well you think
about why i usually date like fat
disgusting drug addicted monsters so
i literally watched them sleep thinking
are they is this it
is this the last breath what's it like
um so far palm springs with um your baby
esther
so far it's been great this this is our
first time to palm springs
and it it's been amazing our
expectations i enjoy the heat
yeah and we go walking every morning
esther's been very cordial and
cordial does she walk you like does she
hold you like
this both of you her arms out i'm
surprised that we have
her uh newfound matureness
oh it's fake mature what was it like
before let's say
let's say immature esther what would
palm springs would have been like with
immature esther
i want to go home
[Laughter]
that's how bad she hates her house she
likes palm springs
no this is the first vacation we've
taken together it's been years
but i have to say that she has planned
and coordinated
everything she's like taken over so i'm
where are you and we just showed up
that's it
so and what else was it like in the in
the past
we do all the work and the planning and
the coordinating
well you just lay there and now when
you're doing things for
esther is she going do more or is she
like this is enough
well she had a breakdown on target and
she says you have to move here i'll do
anything i don't care what it costs
you have to move here she honestly does
seem like she is searching for you guys
and her friends it's just when my mom is
there
it's like she follows me around and like
picks up after me
right which is what you've been trying
to like you've pretty much been
auditioning friends
yeah you know esther i am the exact same
way i am a very
actualized adult until my mom shows up
and i am i've completely regressed into
just being an absolute child
call my hair ma i just don't want to do
anything when she's around just because
you know
and in fact we drove this was her thing
she wasn't supposed to come to palm
springs
i decided to drive late last night
because i needed a car and i asked to
borrow her car and she was like yeah
only if
i get to come as well you treat me to a
breakfast she's like you can borrow the
car she was just seat belted in it
yeah treat me to a breakfast i get to
have a margarita by the pool
and she thought that that was the
vacation but as soon as we walked
through this door
i was like mom can you do this can you
do this and the whole night she just
massaged my head
she's like that's not what i [ __ ]
signed up for you know
oh that's nice so she's here she's here
yeah she's wearing a margarita at the
pool oh
she's hitting on my boyfriend oh you
know well dave and i had a margarita
last night
you split one yeah my mom has not had
alcohol since i was born
really and she dave she like but she had
it while she was pregnant with you
a lot of it but i why did you have a
margarita last night just because dave
wanted it
well yeah he didn't want to drink alone
oh
i thought poor dave he's been drinking
alone this whole time
now do you love dave more than you love
me
well we all love dave everybody loves
dave and we seek his approval
everybody does love now how does dave
act around your parents it seems very
doting to them or
or does he do that sort of dave thing
that makes you want more he takes care
of
us yeah he's very nice but i like what
you said about
when your mother's here you revert back
to when you were a child
yeah yeah do me mommy do me
yeah can it be helped though i just
don't think like
it can be helped well the mother likes
it too you know
yeah esther i do my laundry unless my
mom's with me
then everything is folded for me and i
sit there and i beg
her to do cook for everything mommy this
mommy that
dave and i have gotten to fights before
because dave doesn't like when my mom
does his laundry
but every time she comes the first thing
she does is start doing our laundry
why does he not like it he just says
it's weird that she's like touching his
stuff
his doo-doo pants bobby has no problem
well mary is not happy unless she has a
load in the washing machine
well astr's not happy unless she has a
load in her pants
i'm not the type of person that just can
sit still i have to keep moving all
right if i see a mess i'm going to clean
it dirty
she has that but she doesn't actually do
it and so she's just sitting there with
it
rolling in yeah i'm just sitting there
like wanting it to be done but there's
no way i can move
your head is like spinning that like i
gotta clean i gotta clean and you're
just like
that's why this is a vacation because i
mean it was perfect because if we were
at her house
i probably would have organized it from
top to bottom
yeah well we'll be there tomorrow this
way it gives me a chance
i will say that first morning i did wake
up and i went into her room and i just
started
folding and going through stuff and
organizing
and what did you think of the state of
my house it's in bad shape
a better shape now and this is not an
act this is the way she is she can't
stop
i think it's uh she needs medication but
what was your but what was your life
like before mary were you a slob uh yeah
yeah if there's a word under us or over
us
yeah yeah a little bit you were like one
step up sloppy well i was a [ __ ]
i hadn't been married till i was 44
years old oh what a dog
were you dating a lot though not that
much but
i was 44 and my wife was
28 right and my lawyer said i should
have adopted her
[Laughter]
it might have been cheaper oh my god the
dad jokes have begun
and that was just for me wait how did
you feel after your first sip of alcohol
in
what is it 30 years over 30 years right
yeah she wanted more well no i
i i felt a little tipsy but i was like i
stopped you know i
we didn't finish the drink because
afterwards
we went for a walk and i had to hold on
to him
are you serious and i didn't want to
wake up with a hangover
it's hard to fold when you're drunk too
you gotta have those folding hands ready
and
able what did you guys
uh listen to on the way over here like
what what's a general theme and vibe
can i guess esther complain on road
trips
we don't i don't like if it's a
so this road trip is only two hours and
for me that's not enough
to warrant like a playlist i that's only
enough time for talking
so i would need to be like cross-country
to have like a playlist or a podcast
but i in fact i was thinking because i
need a new car
you know in the next few years
um and i was thinking that the kind of
car i want i want it to be a car where
the front seat and the back seat are
close together
so it's easy for everybody to hear each
other when you're talking
if you you know if everyone's in the car
dependent
it's called a crushed it
yeah it's a weather because my dad in
the back seat like or you know he was
the front seat and he
he can never hear but he's hard of
hearing he needs hearing aids
i know and are you resisting them my
dad's in the same place you don't want
to be an old man right you don't want it
no no
he doesn't want it because it costs
money right
but doesn't it doesn't insurance cover
that no you get [ __ ] whenever
you get to one with the horn
that's the one thing that a kid doesn't
pay for do you want a hearing aid i'll
buy you a hearing aid
one only once while you're ready give
them a tv that has closed captions
and bluetooth so we can wear a headset
that's what my doctor does
you have to listen to it every night he
has it cranked up all the way to the
highest volume
and we fight every night
but you guys have the extra bed like i
feel like if it was me i would just
want to sleep separate i threatened to
but he doesn't want me to sleep in the
other room i'm like are you ready for
separate
rooms yeah is this going is this
happening i'm hoping he'll say
yes who's gonna make my bed
she'll come in you know she'll come in i
know
she'll be drinking her morning coffee or
tea and making your bed
margarita i know now she's drunk i'm
actually this is actually an
intervention we all got here together to
tell you mary
we're very worried about you two empty
bedrooms so i can move into
you know either one of them now that i
stay in the basement i guess you can
have my room
and to esther the upgrade is the
basement how do you guys feel about that
she's fine i'm so glad she's in the
basement now
less trouble in the basement i like the
basement
have you have you slept in a basement
lately
um we didn't have basements where i'm
from
they just had dirt on the ground in the
philippines in philippines
yeah so attics and basements were
really like american novelty for me so
the first time i ever saw someone's
addict i was like what are you do you
only see it in the movies
is that one that's why i went to bobby
because he's an addict
yeah so the first time i went into like
a friend's attic in high school i was
just so
just like oh that's what i saw in them
like it really is
those are the those are like the
nefarious floors it's the attic
and one of my favorite movies growing up
was the um christmas
uh vacation national lampoons with chevy
chase i remember that scene where he's
up in the attic watching that old
movie of his family and then i don't
know if it's uh
randy quaid oh yeah i don't know if it's
him who pulls the thing down
yeah but that whole scene was like stuck
in my head i was like they have those
little
mini things in american homes and so
it's really cool
so no i don't know what it's like
sleeping in a business attic i lived in
the attic
our daisy wasn't finished your room was
in the attic yeah they like finished the
attic was finished though so it was like
you're you had the attic room they put
the girl there two well my older brother
timmy had one and then it was my dad's
office but then i traded but then i was
smoking cigarettes
so i went i know so bad and then not
anymore though
look your dad's kind of into it though
but
mary you got a little competition we
have a spark but
esther how would you feel about became
your mother
[Laughter]
oh my god yesterday my mom wakes up and
they're talking about like
their ages and my mom's like so in a
couple years your dad will be 80
and i'll be 65 and then she goes single
and ready to mingle
my parents are nine years apart but you
guys really you beat him out big time
because it's 15. yeah that's a big
that's a
nice high five do you know what's crazy
is on this
show i mentioned a few weeks ago that my
parents were
married in a courthouse by a blind judge
in chicago
and i got a dm from a listener who was
like hey you should reach out to
the comedian matteo lane because his
grandfather was a blind judge in chicago
matteo lane from new york yeah and i
reached out to him and his grandfather
married my parents all because the
listener of the show messaged me i found
out
ten dollars yeah i had to go grab the
you gave him a five though verified it
was ten dollars to get married
but you slipped him a five because he
was blind i want my money back
is that how you guys got married in a
courthouse dream come true
absolute dream wedding is courthouse
wedding why did you do that
well i was married before and i didn't
need
another wedding and he didn't want to
spend the money
i didn't have anybody to invite because
all my family was out of state
and out of the country and he felt like
if he had a wedding he had to invite all
his aunts and uncles and his cousins
my father had 13 brothers and sisters oh
wow
and uh my mother had nine so
i always feel like the big weddings seem
to be that's got to be so disappointing
for people anyway it's like
do you want a big wedding it's just so
much money for nothing it's like for one
at least a hundred thousand dollars like
that gets you like a
small not that big of like it's just
it's so much money it's crazy and do you
know there's a new
show out it's like they they have
couples on
and they just each couple has to decide
do they want
i think they get 50 000 or something
like that and they have to decide to
either put it towards
their wedding their dream wedding or a
mortgage or a
down payment yes and is there anything
crazier than picking the wedding
over a house you can have the wedding at
the house but
everyone picks the [ __ ] wedding what
it's it's really weird well we know a
couple that
uh remember that that kid that i used to
work with he
he his wife's father asked him if they
wanted a nice wedding or a house
i mean not just a down payment a house
yeah and the wedding was two hundred
thousand dollars
i don't remember him and uh they chose
the wedding they did
that's why you don't remember him
forgettable how dare you make those
decisions
i if it was like i think it's a
clear-cut choice unless the show was
do you want fifty thousand dollars for a
wedding fifty thousand dollars for a
down payment house or fifty thousand
dollars worth of crab legs
fifty thousand dollars worth of sushi i
feel like i
it's a lifetime of wait it's not a lot
oh you're [ __ ] yourself i'm sorry i
shouldn't chris in front of parents
you're bamboozling yourself yeah you're
right because
in front of them do you curse yes yeah
are you kidding me
i really get so confused when i see you
in person i'm so used to
[Laughter]
i heard that this episode today is
sponsored by bluechew
it is bluechew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable form
and at the fraction of the cost and they
deliver to you so you can deliver it to
us
you know annie the big thing do you have
to say it like that
you guys stop blue shoes tablets
help men achieve harder stronger
erections
to combat all forms of erectile
dysfunction blue chew is an online
prescription service so no visits to the
doctor no awkward conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy and
it ships right to your door in a
discreet package the process is simple
sign up at bluechew.com consult with one
of their licensed medical providers
once you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days and the best
part it's
all done online bluetooth tablets are
made in the usa and they prepare and
ship direct so it's cheaper than a
pharmacy
and guess what you guys we've got a
special deal for our listeners you can
try blue chew
free when you use promo code bathgirls
at checkout just pay five dollars for
shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code bathgirls to receive your
first month free
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast you guys this episode is
sponsored by apostrophe a prescription
skin care company for people that are
ready to take their acne seriously
you guys prescription acne treatment
actually works but it's hard to get and
you have to take time off to
off of work to see a doctor and sit in
line at the pharmacy for your
medications is absolutely annoying and
not okay until apostrophe apostrophe
makes it easy to see a board-certified
dermatologist online
you'll get treated immediately and your
medications are delivered to your home
simply fill out apostrophe's online
questionnaire about your skin concerns
and medical history
snap a few selfies and your
dermatologist will get back to the
customized treatment plan tailored just
for you
send your duck face selfie in and get
rid of your acne come on what's better
than that
whatever your skin care goals are
whether it's to treat adult acne reduce
dark spots that's
mine my melasma or improve your skin
texture
um apostrophe gives you that virtual
basically it's a virtual dermatologist
yes and who doesn't want that or need
that
no because i so my dermatologist that i
used to see was
all the way across town just like
traffic expensive parking
now i use apostrophe and my skin is
better and i'm not
wasting a whole day where i could be
facetiming annie
and yeah and on top of that it's like
sometimes like really bad acne
needs to be treated inside out you guys
can get 15
off your first visit with a
board-certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com
bathgirls and use our code bath girls
this coat is only available to our
listeners
so to get started just go to
apostrophe.com bathgirls
and click begin visit and then use code
bath girls at sign up and you'll get 15
off your dermatology visit that's
a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e
dot com slash bathgirls and use the code
bathgirls to get your dermatology visit
for 15
off and we thank you apostrophe for
sponsoring this podcast
esther if you go to japan they take
these big like tuna fish right
and they're worth millions right they're
they're big
50 000 you get a slab
so yeah you're i'm think thankfully you
have me for that intervention
i would never have you choose this dude
sugarfish okay fine 50 000
of oat milk lattes that's a better
choice
just have a small backyard wedding you
know immediate family
and say your id dudes and you're done
with that yeah
but you wanted a dance number yeah i
here's one thing i was thinking that was
appealing to me lately was if i could
put on like a really
like a romantic gesture musical number
for dave
a review he'd be so embarrassed by that
oh my god there's nothing more
embarrassing
all your friends flash him as you're
doing it no i would do a big musical
review in front of him and all his
friends
family and be all about how much i love
him
that that appeals to me what and if you
did just pictures of him throughout his
life but no
there's not a view it's just him that
would be like his childhood bedroom why
don't all three of you get married at
the same time
i know we're gonna try if we have kids
we're gonna try to plan that together
well
let me just say that i tell you that
you're gonna have a kid with us at the
same time no i remember
yeah that's that's a for sure we already
that was a blood pack right
i told i told bobby i was like look this
is the deal i made a deal with those
devils we're trying to get our
tabulation all together wait let's talk
wedding though
because that would be fun if we you are
you
when we first started this show yeah you
mentioned to us i'm half engaged
we're unsure of where that stands for we
can get a hold of that blind judge
oh my god
i would marry bobby for the clothes uh
good choice the clothes sharing
yes now what do you mean you're half
engaged because you told us that
this was kind of happening it seemed
like right so he had
asked in a very um nonchalant very
unemotional way and i rejected that
and um we sat down in therapy and i was
like look i'm not normally
somebody who like likes weddings or even
cares about like ever being engaged
i was like but the way he asked me
made it just altogether worse for me
like i wish he hadn't even asked at all
i wish he had just gone we had just gone
our whole lives together
never even mentioning the thought of a
wedding but the way he asked me made me
feel like oh is this relationship over
how did he ask you he said uh planned
the weather
wedding that's exactly how we said it
hey he was like
it wasn't even a question it was like he
just commanded you yeah he was
he i was packing his clothes for hawaii
packing his suitcase and he was like hey
babe plan a wedding i'm gonna go play
war zone and then he went back to his
video game
and i was like you know what would have
been awesome though if as he said that
and you were packing his things like
in the bottom of his thing like in socks
it was like marry me and there was like
a little
something something any gesture would
have been fine besides that gesture
now this brings me to the next question
is annie
would you like
would you marry todd and what would that
who would propose to who
who gave her this gene this is a very
uncomfortable gene
it's a very like incredible positive if
you're uncomfortable it's from him
but it's not easy we live no we live the
same life
uncomfortable as my dad knows he is my
mom
listen jokes at you is your dad mean
ones about you
is a combo i
by the way that was really funny when i
walked in and i said i'm so fat today
and andy was like it's just
your mom is in town you're not happy
your mom's in town
we've all been through it okay i feel
the exact same way
the honest sharp tongue of a mother
esther you and i actually have a lot of
things in common
what um when i we're both beautiful well
yes
but my mom is very fit and youthful
and in a lot better shape than me so
when i'm standing next to her
um my self-esteem collapses i'm like god
um somehow yeah i just and she
she always says things like don't worry
you're just like me when you get
pregnant you're just gonna snap back
like that
i'm like i don't think so i haven't had
a baby and i haven't snapped back
i know i'm waiting to snap once
you really embraced the part of palm
springs it's like a retired older
person that wants to play golf just be
comfortable
just be comfortable yeah well
my mom never says you're just like me
because she told me that when i was in
college and i gained weight she's like
you gain more weight than i did when i
was nine months pregnant with you
but you were a two pound baby if that
does help
that's true but would how what would a
proposal with todd even look like
i mean i'm definitely not ready for that
i think i would be like
i i we don't talk like we're gonna break
up at any point but i
i'm definitely not like i make it clear
that
maybe but here's what i really like
about
russian to walk down the altar i'm not
i'm not like yeah it's we've been
together a year it's
it's all been in covet i'm excited to
get life back to normalcy but i you know
i've never
had a better boyfriend i love him i love
todd yeah
he bought you two so you oh my god he's
so dead to me because of those actually
can you pass those to me am i not gonna
marry him here's what happened
guys so annie we're at queue a party
this is a party motel springs and annie
said todd go get me some swimsuits
i think that he did a great job look at
this yes this
i agree and a high waistline oh why
would i bottom
and then you threw it at his face and
said you're single no you know what you
don't like is that it's high
cut bikini it's disgusting no you don't
want not high cut
yes i do i just want a string bikini a
regular thing that he sees oh you want a
string bikini
i got a chance oh it's a tan
so i'm going to have a line right here i
wear my stomach out
i actually don't think look it's a yubi
okay that one is hideous it's like one
grandmother did he get that for that one
is weird that he got it
well look guys are stupid guys are
really stupid i also said do not get me
a one piece
they have no sense of fashion no dude
one time you know our friend john
campanelli he during the pandemic
he was going to the grocery this is like
before like i was going to grocery
stores like right when it started
and he was going to grocery store so i
was like can you please just get me
some garlic like i'm about to cook
something i just need garlic
and he comes over with two onions
and i'm just like he's like oh i thought
garlic and onions were the same
oh no who raised them i thought it was
just like guys are
dumb like it's just got i feel like some
guys just they
they're like lacking those that's for
sure
what's an onion he could have it would
have been smart if he had gotten
something like a shallot something
that's sort of in
totally honestly you know what those
swimsuits do feel like i asked for a
garlic and i got an onion
get me like what i always wear i don't
know i just like do not get me a one
piece but
i think he got you one garlic one onion
but you know what i will tell you
something
you i'd have learned in life you cannot
tell people what you don't want because
they just hear the word and then they
get you you don't want so you always
have to say the thing you want
i should have said i want a string
bikini when you ask here's the lesson
when you ask a guy for garlic
he's going to bring you onions yeah you
have to go
maybe but i just can't even believe he
did that for you see she's auditioning
mothers my dad never used to pay for
bulbs in general onion garlic or
shallots lights no light in the house
bulbs nothing
he just thought that bulbs were from the
earth and that everything
garlic and onion should be free they
shouldn't be farmed and that we should
he would shove garlic and onion in his
pocket buy the rest of the groceries and
never pay for the garlic
oh he would just steal his steel bulbs
and that was his thing that was
his uh life motto don't pay for bulbs
that sounds like someone i know i like
his style
yeah like if it comes from the dirt it's
mine yes
i mean farmers have to make it though i
mean sure
but you know his thing is it's like such
a basic
basis for all foods that we cook yeah
you need it it's almost like
you shouldn't pay for salt either kind
of thing
um so he had his own theories about
maybe you shouldn't pay for
food either if you farm yourself yeah
but if there's labor there you should
[ __ ] pay for it food should be free
can the government give us now i'm a
socialist but can the government give us
food
you know how bad the food would be
that's so true it would be way worse
than like lunchroom
so many carbs we'd be all eating gluten
let's just say that
now mom speaking of lunchrooms you used
to work
in the lunchroom in my elementary school
what was it like what was it like when i
came into the lunchroom every day but
wait were you working there to
actually have the job or to keep an eye
on your little munchkin
uh part-time job just to get out of here
yeah yeah
and what was it like when i came in the
lunchroom she couldn't see you you were
under the thing
she was always happy to see me come on
that's so
cute i know that's so cool to have your
mom working yes
but see you know some kids are really
ashamed when they're paint when they see
their parents in school that's one
middle for me that was middle school
middle school junior high yeah junior
high i was embarrassed guys started
hitting on her
when no like when one day she came to
pick me up from school
on halloween she was wearing a witch's
hat and that was like
horrifying just be happy that it was on
halloween imagine any other day that
would be way worse
that would be your parents annie yeah i
know my own do you know what my parents
did to me once oh my god they picked me
up i was in hawaii
um and i come back that was my dolphin
training time
i came back they were in the
philadelphia airport
wearing rasta wigs with the racist
dreadlocks
in the philadelphia airport i was the
only white person on the plane
they came out they're like yeah man i
had like dolphins like um
dolphin uh what do you call them
balloons
it was just such a spectacle it was so
embarrassing i was like
oh my god now mom you watch bloodbath
every week
yes i do i'm a huge fan i love it
oh mary you're a slug you're an honorary
slug i do
i love it what do you think of it i
think you girls are great
you're entertaining i laugh we got
chemistry
yeah i can't talk while she's watching
it she's just going into it really
and it's tuesday right away sometimes
it's time
yeah tuesdays at nine a.m uh california
time all right she's
she loves him yeah and you're listening
while cleaning
no you're focused i'm totally focused
yes
i sit there the whole hour and eight
minutes fourteen minutes
so you're all caught up you know all our
deepest darkest i'm so jealous of that
clothes are laying all over the floor
my dad's laying there he's his diaper
chains
legs up he's very flexible
[Laughter]
he's hungry i always say to todd i'm
always like i cannot believe you left my
mess out here
this is ridiculous no i'm very happy for
you girls
thank you thank you we're so glad you're
watching do you feel like we've come so
far
are you proud i mean every episode gets
better and better
esther and i did this i guess forever
ago and she goes
um she's like um
oh you shave your happy trail do you
care if i said that and i was like
yeah you can't say what i should already
say it's so funny
wait happy trails are something to be
embarrassed about this was like
2013. i thought it was something to grow
out
grow out of i always i've always had a
hairy
hairy stomach and i've never cared
little pets to play with
this is a net kalila grew up in the
philippines
yes we're gonna take a trip there what
do you think about your daughter in the
philippines are you worried
esther i actually think the philippines
is a match for you people are very
sweet and doting and it's a place
where someone any old person can feel
like royalty in a princess
hand and foot served hand and foot
what's the food like
um very basic do you like rice yes a lot
of organic stuff like
um grilled you know grilled vegetables
rice soups lots of lots of fruits
very clean stuff to eat is the fruit
really fresh and tasty there the best
the best unmatched palm trees i think
you're surprised it's gonna surprise the
[ __ ] out of you do you think you'll get
married
there i will get married aren't we all
having a joint wedding now
yeah we're getting married there oh my
god we should sell tickets to it
guys the tickets are ten thousand
dollars
great malls
do you like malls yes what do you mean
do i like mom the mall of asia
is going to blow your mind it's the it's
it's bigger than the mall of america
it's bigger than that will you please do
a show with me at mall of america are
you crazy
to i had the most fun she was just like
i've never had more fun in my life you
were killing us me and my mom are
obsessed with did you see me get
old-timey photos by myself
when i was little they did too yeah we
all definitely all three have to do it
yeah i've never we're just i mean
your dad might paint my parents had a
house right across the river
and from their sun room you could see
the mall of america
from the the parking garage yeah
so anyways yeah it's right over the
river i've never been happier i couldn't
believe
there's no attacks on clothes did you
buy it
no did you go on any rides i did i went
on rides but you know i met people it
was actually embarrassing i met
these guys came up to me and they were
like you should go on the rides with us
and i was like oh you're coming to the
show tonight and they're like what show
[Laughter]
some weirdos hitting on me so i run on
the rides with them and then they came
to the show for free and then we're rude
to the
wait staff we used to take her there
when she was a toddler i mean all the
way
growing up and my grandchildren did you
go on rides you didn't go on rides
yeah no ride-person level rides okay is
it still called camp snoopy or it's
nickelodeon world it's nickelodeon
okay so he used to be camp snoopy but
the rides at mall america are the best
because they're not
that scary so you have this roller
coaster
that's really fun but it's so easy so
that's like the only roller coaster that
i can be successful on
successful how about the log ride that
water oh that's
the only thing to be successful on a
roller coaster is to not fall out
and that is i when i'm on our scary
roller coaster the one time i ever did
it with my sister
at six flags in chicagoland i
thought to myself i'd rather jump off to
my death than stay on this
i hated it did you were you on your
tiptoes to get on the ride to begin with
a little worried dangling you know
that's my top question
i'm getting on the road now is how tall
is esther i'm like it's
it's on google yeah but it's is it is it
google accurate
i actually don't know because he says
i'm trans so i don't know what else
google says we have we were talking
about this before there's a girl that we
know
whose uh birthday says that she's 10
years older than she is online
oh that's right you know from sarah
weinstein sarah weinshank's
her she's like 32 or something and her
wikipedia says she's like 43. and i that
was a juicy hakka so i go guys if she's
i am go we're doomed there is no way i
am going to find out what's on her face
well esther your wikipedia says you two
are married oh it does
yes oh yeah didn't it say she's my
partner who's the boy
who wrote that
wait it was the bottom yeah who's the
bottom
what we're both women there's no bottom
there's always there's still a bag my
family is here okay yeah you're right
your mom would be watching this anyway
who do you guys think like made her good
and who made her bad
no that's obvious
[Laughter]
well we used to call her rosemary's baby
and she had a little bassinet
that she slept with in our room and it
looked like you know the one in the
movie yeah
so we tagged her uh rosemary's baby
and now did was it hard getting it into
the basement for her now or
no i definitely think my wife is the
good influence and i was the
kind of devilish
well isn't it true that that dad would
wake me up when i was napping
oh yeah he yeah just a whole nother
house
no i had so much fun with her
you know well i'd wake her up and say
come on let's play aunts and uncles
would just drop
in and if she was taking a nap he didn't
care i'd say she's sleeping
let her be oh no he'd go in just scoop
her up bring her down oh my god
show her off yeah i must be your dad too
oh and then he let her
sleep with us he wanted her to sleep in
bed with us oh
go sleep that was a big
mistake because that child never went
back into her crowd i honestly do think
that that
is explains a lot yeah i
the nice very needy then she's very
clingy yes she's a clinger yeah not
anymore though
she's a big girl now i know look dave
says that i have adult attachment
issues yeah you're anxious attached
okay so you guys we all know that we
should drink more water
but by the time you feel thirsty it's
too late
where's tip if you're already dehydrated
and you're just drinking water you're
just diluting your electrolytes even
more
that's crazy which is why you need
something like hydrant
so hydrant is a refreshing drink mix
powder made with four key electrolytes
sodium potassium magnesium and zinc and
it's made with real fruit juice powder
and no artificial sweeteners or
synthetic colors no nonsense all science
so
i used to reach for like those normal
drinks at the 7-eleven or whatever
they're full of sugar
but this i got a pack of hydrant i feel
so much better when i drink it i'm
actually hydrated
also they now have hydrant sleep which
is a new bedtime mix carefully
formulated to promote restful sleep and
hydration hydrant sleep includes
melatonin
magnesium l-theanine gaba and chamomile
to promote restful
high-quality sleep guys we've got a
special deal for our listeners to save
off your first order or subscribe and
save 30
on your first subscription order go to
drink hydrant.com
bathgirls or enter our promo code
bathgirls at checkout
that's d
r a d-r-i-n-k-h-y-d-r-a-n t dot com
slash bathgirls and enter the promo code
bathgirls for 20
off your first order drink hydrant.com
bathgirls and enter the promo code
bathgirls to save 20
and we thank them for sponsoring this
podcast hydrant where
water meets wellness do you ever get um
anxiety and depression over your
swelling uh we'll check out my armpits
guys
this is proof i suffer from anxiety i
suffer from depression i suffer from
um you know family troubles the whole
the list same
girl who doesn't by the way
there's no shame in that suffering
because now you can get the help with
better help better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist and
connect you in a safe and private online
environment it's so convenient
and you can start communicating in under
48 hours from right now
you can send a message to your counselor
anytime this is actually my favorite
feature is the journal feature because
you get timely and thoughtful responses
plus you can schedule weekly video or
phone sessions
dude you know what i love about better
help is i have friends who freaking
need therapy and all these years they
say oh i can't afford it i can't afford
it i go
hey you're gonna try better help now
okay honestly
also there's financial aid financial aid
is available
and anything you share is confidential
it's convenient it's professional it's
affordable
check out the testimonials posted daily
on their site it's not a crisis line
it's therapy we want you to start living
a happier life today
as a listener you'll get 10 off your
first month by visiting our sponsor at
betterhelp.com
bloodbath join over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
again that's betterhelphelp.com
bloodbath and then so
then i would sleep on the floor she was
in our room
and then she slept with leah for a
couple years
and then my sister kicked me out because
she said i had dead skin cells
and then we tried her back in her bed
where i would
you know lie down with her and wait for
her to fall asleep
and tip your toe out mom where are you
going nowhere
then we put the sleeping bag on the
floor in our room and she must have
slept there until junior
whatever whatever you do don't mention
how he locked her in the room
with the gate we know the game one night
you think i don't think about her like
this
all the time i just imagine i don't know
this story we tried tough love
one night and we've never heard the end
of this
one tell them what to tell them what
happened so we put the gate up and mind
you
by her bedroom door there's a flight of
stairs
okay so it was for her safety okay
her safety so if she got up in the
middle of the night she didn't tumble
down the stairs
yeah and saw the keeper in her room and
so she just
cried and cried and cried it was like
one two o'clock i mean we were like
going out of her mind
she thought she's on death row when is
this child gonna give it up
and she's still crying it's so weird and
then finally she got quiet
and then we went in to see and she was
sleeping on the floor next to the gate
i thought i was hanging on to the gate
this is junior high
how old was i was this pre or post jacob
the dog
but the gate that they [ __ ] locked me
behind they still
use it so every time i go home i have to
see this gate that tormented me
and they use it to they have it up
against the stairs the dogs can't go
got to side with their parents on this
one this is crazy
she's like they have my trigger and gate
and also it is just a baby gate and a
dog gate that's what they're for when we
want her to leave we bring out the gauge
she runs she runs the therapy
you know i recently heard that there's
this celebrity that i won't name that
they have it like a beautiful guest
house and that they
keep the guest house so the cold only
has cold water
so that guests won't stay too long why
what oh is this not a public story
no it's not a public store that they're
like well how are they
they can't shower no it's they just say
like oh our cold our
water hot water is broken in the guest
house they've got to be canadian this is
a very passive aggressive thing
they made a mistake because there are
people who didn't grow up with hot water
just like myself who would
if it's a nice enough guest house that's
a small cold water is a small price tag
this is a celebrity home it's like why
not oh yeah if all the amenities just
cold water
and then you seem like the cool guest
you're like oh i don't care when really
they're like
knuckles in my nose yeah like no it's
really cool i'm fine i would never let
anyone know if i was upset about that
could you really take cold showers yeah
it's good for you they're good for you
you're like the whole hot thing it's
good for your hair and yeah don't you
dare at the very end
yeah i said the very uh how do i know
that about your life i do the exact same
thing mary yeah
um so it's ten minutes of hot the last
two minutes is as cold as i
as it goes well she's finished so they
do that in finland we'll take the sound
and then back and forth yeah did you
ever think he was divorcing you when he
said you're finished
i was like oh my god they're doing it
right now
um should we take a banana break yeah
with no oh [ __ ] we'll watch you eat i
would like all of us to watch you eat an
apple
i should just pantomime a banana break
wait are you guys going to be okay
without a snack yes
i have a big snack yeah george this is a
great banana
well that was fun thank you oh it's
great seeing you annie
i know i love you guys i love your
little pleasure meeting you
nice to meet you i love your weird
little monster you made
i know where all the tables it's a
banana break
and only esther has an apple what are
your overall um
thoughts and feelings about palm springs
so far
i know this was a very um one
last minute thing for us annie are you
guys sharing a room yes
okay now what are i'm jealous about
and this is the options i gave annie i
said do you want to stay
in the fancy or a bougie place or or
do we want to go tacky she's like do you
even know who you're typing
obviously tacky and look this is a super
eighth basically
i love this place um
i really like palm springs because i
like the mid-century architecture it
reminds me my hometown
um i like that it gets so so so hot that
you can't help but get in the pool
this is how we teach her to swim i saw
you in a pair of goggles yesterday and
let me tell you
never been more excited in my life i was
like is this truly happening
and i wrote dave back because he posted
that picture of you and goggles she's
actually i believe in her what's
happening give me a play-by-play
and he said nothing you're still gonna
have to teach her how to put no she put
the goggles on for when she
when you teach her to keegal oh my god
no
the you know what is so fascinating to
me is being able to look
at water to being able to open your eyes
underwater with goggles on
that is like a high i'm gonna teach you
what did you do today
girl i'm gonna teach you the way i
taught my
my kids to swim not my children but when
i used to do a learn to swim program
get their favorite toy drop it at the
bottom and tell them to retrieve it
and they they really want their toy back
so they eventually learn how to
hold their breath so to throw sushi at
the bottom basically
are you guys going to swim while you're
here um i have to drive back home
tonight this is a very quick turnaround
trip for me
but annie has two swimsuits i've got two
[ __ ] switches to choose from some
now kyla what do you think of palm
springs i love palm springs i come here
often
um because i just love the desert
there's something that i
i don't know i think it's a magical
place it's weird it's like you have
i don't know people from all different
also
palm springs is very very gay the
essence of palm springs is super
um gay and i love gay people yeah
it just brings me so much joy when i
look out this window here i'm like oh my
god this is such like a
that's todd dude my god kissing a guy
todd's totally hanging out with my mom
we drove past liberace's house yesterday
it was so cool
did you feel i don't really know
anything about liberace but his house
seemed cool
yeah i get him confused with the guy who
got bit by the tiger
oh uh siegfried wait hang on liberace
did matt damon play him
yeah no didn't he play his lover oh his
lover
his lover who was liberace oh it was um
what's his name
married to catherine zeta uh uh michael
douglas
michael douglas he blamed his throat
cancer on
eating out uh catherine zader jones did
he really you know what
i'll tell you why um i believe that
what because a very close family a
member member of mine which will remain
unnamed who will remain unnamed
um had to have his throat to figure it
same thing because hpv helped up with uh
catherine well another person with
hpv and got the thrilled hpv
and so um i do believe that narrative
well guys we thought you were making it
up and look at us now
well it only makes sense it's only sort
of like hpv only really manifests itself
in women right
down there so it only makes sense that
the men can yeah wait
did he really publicly say that yeah no
he didn't
he did mom look at your mom your mom's
nodding
okay here here's what i need your
thoughts on i want to know what your
thoughts on i don't know
today this has been a long episode it's
not really weirdest yesterday's parents
i'm kind of thrown off
the benefit reunion what the benefit
reunion
thrilled j.lo and ben affleck literally
bringing me
my youth back bringing me back to the
best time of my life
and there were gili billboards plastered
across the country
only person that julie was a good part
of their life i
bought a replica of the pink diamond
ring
that he gave her i ordered it from a
catalog it was my favorite ring
i used jlo had did a a clothing line
collaboration back in the day i used to
have jlo jeans
like this is just reminding me of the
good days what about you guys
i feel the exact same way i'm so excited
yeah what they've done for all of us
is like amazing we already know that
it's
probably not like this emotional love
affair they're having it's just really
good sex you know it's just really good
sex
you know it was she couldn't forget that
bomb has sick
he couldn't forget oh my god do we have
to do this way [ __ ]
it's true that's the feeling i get
because it's totally a rebound number
one
i think it's a nostalgia thing i think
it's just as what it is for us as it is
for them
it's like let's remind ourselves of the
good old days you know i always say when
i drive past my high school
ex-boyfriend's house it's not because of
him it's because of the memories of that
age
so but they're doing it esther how do
you know they're not just sitting in a
diner reminiscing about their once love
affair that was plastered all over mtv
they're doing it and i mean helicopter
style
how do you know that it's just i feel it
i look at their pictures together in
montana and i can just feel it in my
chest i just know it inherently that
that's what's happening
um i honestly i posted a meme that
somebody made about it but
how like she's been back with him for
like two minutes and he's already hotter
again
like he was so disgusting yeah i was
like batman really and i'm like you
should make him batman and [ __ ] rob
and make him all of them
he should be every single character i
wonder because you know how
i wonder if this this stuff is true like
how there really are pr
relationships like it's a publicity
stunt is there any world oh we are
one now did you think that tom what's
his name and taylor swift tom
hiddleston mm-hmm do you think that was
a pr stunt
who's tom hiddleston he plays the guy in
thor
the other guy what's this oh yeah yeah
yeah
loki i don't think it was a pr stunt i
just wonder if this one is because he
just had
really bad publicity because somebody
released somebody leaked videos of him
dm yeah being like hey it really is me
which is so embarrassing like he's
dm'ing girls on instagram saying like
look it's me ben affleck it's like
that's lame
as lame as that is i didn't feel like it
was as bad as everyone else
why yes because i think because the girl
the girl even said
she said i unmatched with him because i
didn't think it was him
and then he was like it's me and it's
like so you got your confirmation and
now it's like you made a choice
well i guess i don't like ben affleck
enough to go on a date with him instead
i'll just blast him
what's a 90s or 2000s couple that you
would love to see reunite
really it's hard to beat ben affleck and
jennifer i mean brad pitt and janet when
those
were going around that was exciting can
i give you one that's a dream of mine
yeah and i know she's married to james
brolin but if barbara's try sand and
andre agassi
got back together do you remember that
relationship i was really into tennis
so do you guys know who andre agassi is
yes but do you know that he was with
barbra streisand
do you know who needs to get back
together ryan gosling and
when she was 75 years older than him she
was he was pushing her around i was like
this is the hottest
and now i get it that one was because my
it reminded me yesterday my mom and i
drove out here at midnight
and we listened to the whole yentl
soundtrack because that's our favorite
thing we listened to it twice over
oh my god my mom i wanted to address
something very important
george you partly to blame for this so
on bad friends
my lover my partner andrew
my future baby's father
um has slandered me george and you're
aware of this aren't you
i just saw it yeah it's bad it's bad
it's bad
he's telling people that i hit him
bobbius
yeah she's being called a domestic
abuser in the comments
we were watching a ufc fight
right we were watching a ufc fight where
there were two women fighting
one was the world champion who happened
to be chinese
world champion and another one from
she's from colorado um and i happen to
be rooting for the chinese
girl because she's the world champion
and i love her
anyways the chinese girl gets knocked
out
and it was a brutal knockout bobby
starts gloating and celebrating
i feel bad because the girl that i was
rooting for not for any other reason but
the fact that i love this girl
gets brutally ko'd and i'm crying i'm
like oh my god
poor whaley poor whaley and he's
gloating
and so i do one of these to him and i
was like [ __ ] and do this
i was like shut the [ __ ] like that and
now he's telling everybody that i
like i i backhanded him and across the
face and he's slandering me what should
i do
hit him everyone's racist and a domestic
abuser why are you racist
because there it's like white people
going like oh you only root for the
asian
she just wasn't a random asian girl
she's a world champion you're allowed to
root and also you can
root for the asian yeah i i can okay yes
i is that bad well then she's also just
a [ __ ] badass like she's
amazing but um i i don't know if i
should call him to clarify
yeah because he needs help
well you know what the fans want my mom
just said yeah
okay um so i have a question since i've
been getting a lot of
very hateful emails about being um
number one a racist
and number one a domestic abuser why on
earth would you go on your podcast and
tell people that i hit you
because i don't know why i'm a liar
why would you say something that like
that's a big accusation
do you realize that i know but you
you you touched my face a little bit
though
i might have after like in a sweet way
no you were gonna go full force but then
you held back i think no i did one of
those i did one of these i didn't
you know but it was just to scare you
it's just what we do in the streets
you were scared for my life
and so you retaliated by telling people
i was uh that i abused you physically
during stop asian hate to say that your
girlfriend hit an
asian i know you're coming after me i'm
asian too okay i know i'm like white
passing but i'm still asian
i mean i'll apologize to you on the
podcast wait hang on one second
what why are they calling me a racist
i don't know why you're not a racist but
why what did you say do you remember
i don't know the voice going on
george george is raising his hand why
are they calling me racist george
cause bobby said he wasn't allowed to
cheer for the white girl
[Music]
okay i love you bye bye bobby bye babe
why is he there
he's a shooting are you okay without him
um i'm not we both like cried a lot
really yeah we've never been apart this
long we're just
i don't know what the schedule hangs
might you go
um the eu is not open for tourists yet
oh
yeah you go i'm sorry young [ __ ]
did you have a query i wanted to ask you
guys we were talking about 90s and 2000s
relationships
gun to your head if you had to get back
with one x
who would it be big big gun to your head
i take the bullet i think
yeah i'd just say next life let's go out
together
yeah i know your exes i wouldn't allow
it it would be a murder-suicide baby
yeah i can't oh god have you ever
backpedaled though like have you ever
broken up and then
you know hooked up with an ex before and
then oh well i've never
dumped anyone i've always been dumped
really
yeah i've never broken up with anyone so
i
would never have the choice even if
you're miserable have you ever been
miserable but just never like broke it
off anyways you just stick it out
i'm if someone is near me i'm not that
miserable
it's fine it will be fine
um esther calls her friends space
heaters
yeah i've revisited x's i used to have
like i had like one guy that would like
i would say he would like [ __ ] start me
again like i'd go through a breakup and
then i'd go back to him or whatever
then i got over that and then um and he
may be in this room just kidding oh
my god make me sick
but yeah it's always a not a
you never need to go back i i i think
once you once you're out of your 20s you
can't go back to so you're saying that
benefit has no [ __ ]
no chance i think that they maybe that
they were
like there was pressures from society
or something or different places in
their career
i mean if you're both rich it's like you
know what the best part about them being
back together is that
there is a song that jlo wrote called
i'm glad
i'm glad when i make it love to you it's
such a good song
i spun to that on peloton yesterday so
she hasn't sung it live
since they broke up because she wrote
about him so it's like
you know too juicy or whatever and she
just recently did a performance of it
which is like a huge deal but it makes
sense for them right because he also has
like struggled with addiction and stuff
and maybe he's in a better place and she
just got [ __ ] over so bad that maybe
she's like
what happened with her i think he
cheated on her i think hey
with well allegedly with that um reality
star right
oh i don't know yeah or i don't know who
he was philandering with but there was
rumor that that might have been the
cause of it it definitely is a really
good example
of that saying where people say one plus
one equals three
like them together is more than them
separate like it's just such a
they've just they've one-upped the world
i feel like do you think p did it is
like god damn it
that could have been me
[Laughter]
he really fell off but he if someone
posted something i saw where it was like
him um coming into his like
giant living room or whatever and he had
like
all these balloons and he's like every
friday i just buy myself a bunch of
balloons
and i was like i love this p today
that's like such a good message
yeah it was good right yeah it was a
tick tock yeah yeah
do you remember when he used to have the
all-white parties in san tropez
yeah that was in the 2000s and we'd be
reading it in our magazines like one day
i think they still have them they'll
white parties yeah
oh i just thought i think i think maybe
it's just not as big a deal it's like
easier to get into like i think someone
went to one yeah it's like going to a ja
rule party yeah
i could never go because i could never
wear all white because you're going to
play it all over it because
look at annie today she's on the way
head to toe
this is my one time wearing this again
wait why not i'll wait for you esther i
just don't have that kind of confidence
well what's with all i don't get it
white's so flattering
what else never getting married she's
like i just look bad and white
white is the opposite of flattering it
makes you look bigger okay what color
is your wedding dress gonna be black
she's gonna have a wedding dress painted
on it that makes her look skinnier yes
let's just throw you an indian wedding
you don't have to wear a white dress in
fact it's like forbidden you have to
wear a bright
like red or a bright color that will
henna you up you actually would look
cute and
indian stuff okay but you know like the
lengas the
um the crop top and the skirt is really
flattering
really oh it yes i like that look the
high-waisted high-waisted skirt
and then you have the thing over it too
kim kardashian kind of brought that back
i feel like
interesting i had a lot of a trouble oh
remember when it skims gonna be called
kimono yeah
oh was it yeah yeah it was and everyone
freaked out thank god because how shitty
would
come out that's one relationship i
wouldn't be opposed to
just go back to her roots and start
dating ray j again what
that's all right well that's been
uh me in a hotel room with my friends
talking about sex in front of my parents
beautiful thank you in beautiful palm
springs um
thanks for crashing my family vacay i
needed the break
we're not that sorry i um the only thing
i've ever held back was my own heroine
and vomiting
[Laughter]
thanks for letting us crash her party
one more thing are we doing drugs
tonight you and i
what what drugs either
this is their one shot at freedom you
and i we're finally sharing a hotel room
i mean you didn't tell me to bring drugs
i don't have any drugs you're right and
i don't do drugs either i'm a square
drum i really am i've never done any
this it was your
it was look this could have been your
wheel of fortune moment i've never done
any drugs
but alcohol and weed um and what would i
bring you like i would make you do
mushrooms
yeah mushrooms would have been why don't
we save it for the next time we come to
palm springs we'll leave my parents at
home
we'll rent a little house together we'll
do mushrooms no
i'll watch you do mushrooms and you'll
also then the next day you'll teach me
how to swim
yes yeah let's do that soon okay well
thank you guys for listening um
i my clothing line is finally gonna have
a new drop sleepover by esther.com there
should be merch up there now
check it out maybe i'll get his uh
outfit or two
you will at this point i might just get
it and just never post it
i just wear it in private so that's it
yeah thanks guys
see you guys next week
[Music]
you